[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
it's only monday morning
and elon musk has completely ruined
twitter
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
jesus christ
elon musk buys over nine percent of
twitter
i said it's time for breakfast eon musk
hashtag eat the rich i think that's what
we should do
hello
elon musk elon musk buys nine percent of
twitter i don't know if it's a good
thing or a bad thing we're gonna run
through it today though because it's in
the tweety tweets and attorney trends
and this monday morning there is a
[ __ ] shitload trending
when you talk about politics
tons of politics trending
there was a trump rally this weekend
i mean if you want to call it that
it's like a q anon gathering more than
anything and it's getting [ __ ]
ridiculous
it's not even like it's not even about
like policy anymore they don't even say
anything about like government or
[ __ ] policy or
it's all about hunter biden's laptop and
space force
i'm gonna show you it's [ __ ] wild as
[ __ ] like a [ __ ] circus i don't know
if they set up a tent when they had
these [ __ ] nazi rallies or not but
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i'd rather eat ten bags of dog [ __ ]
than go to a [ __ ] trump rally holy
actual [ __ ] you guys see the clips from
this thing
baby
everyone's running around going oh my
god what's wrong with our country
what's wrong with our country well these
people
these people have a microphone
that's what's wrong
it's a cue and honors
and the media doesn't help because they
both sides things you know like sam
stein this morning's like oh lindsey
graham said if this if the republicans
were in charge of the senate
katanji brown jackson wouldn't even get
a hearing and sam stein's like oh well
it looks like both sides will never get
the [ __ ] out of here with your bullseye
and [ __ ]
sam stein puck your head out of your ass
sam stein is not a stupid [ __ ] person
he's not a bad journalist he's just
doing bad journalism
stop both sides and [ __ ] there are no
both sides
stop that [ __ ]
there's only one side in this country
that is against democracy only [ __ ]
won
and they all gathered up at a rally this
weekend
to [ __ ] praise their orange mussolini
jesus
to worship at the altar of trump it's a
cult it's a [ __ ] cult
sam stein had another great [ __ ]
another great epiphany this weekend he's
like why in the hell why in the hell do
americans believe that we're losing jobs
in this country 30 percent of americans
think we're losing jobs unemployment's
3.6 percent oh that's [ __ ] unreal who
would have thought that if the media
doesn't do their [ __ ] job if the free
press doesn't report on the [ __ ] that's
going on that the country won't [ __ ]
know
that there'll be a vacuum in the gap you
dumb [ __ ]
this is why so many people are pissed
off at the media and it ain't got to do
with it we think they're the enemy i
don't think the media is the enemy i
think it's the exact opposite
i mean it may be its own worst enemy
that may be true
but they're not the enemy
they just aren't doing their [ __ ]
jobs they're in the trump loop i've said
this a time and time again they're in
the trump loop right they're in this
[ __ ] loop where they think the
president united states destroys
everything because they went through
four years of it
every [ __ ] day he was kicking over so
much [ __ ] they couldn't even keep up
and now they're like oh well there's a
guy he seems to be kicking over things
maybe maybe both sides kick over
everything maybe both sides you're
against americans maybe both sides are
anti-democrat no they're not
they're not
both sides are not anti-norm both sides
are not anti-government both sides are
not anti-democracy
they're not
stop with that [ __ ] and there's no
better example
than judge brown jackson
there's no better [ __ ] example
the [ __ ] republicans were whining and
complaining that they couldn't ask judge
brown jackson about her sexual assault
allegations because there are none
they couldn't ask her why
she hid her bigotry behind her religious
dogma because she doesn't
they couldn't ask her why she's not
qualified to be a supreme court justice
because she is
you [ __ ] boneheads
stop with your nonsense you're both
siding nonsense [ __ ] stop trying to
appear to be fair and balanced there is
no fair there is no balance
just go look at the clips
from the trump rally
if you want to know that both sides are
completely different they're not the
same
they're not
and this both sides are the same [ __ ]
this narrative that even the media can't
help themselves
is a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ]
a whole [ __ ] truckload of horseshit
get out your shovels american people
standing around wondering why people
don't know that the unemployment rate is
3.6 percent
maybe because you're focusing on hunter
biden's laptop hunter biden he owned no
laptop he emailed people
he may have committed crimes who gives a
fine [ __ ]
who cares if [ __ ] that degenerate
hunter biden committed crimes so [ __ ]
charge him
just like you should charge donald trump
donald trump jr ivanka trump and jared
kushner and eric trump to boot
charge them [ __ ] what are you waiting on
charge hunter biden if he committed
crimes
no democrat in anywhere in this country
gives two flying [ __ ] if hunter biden
committed crime don't give a [ __ ]
don't give a [ __ ] and if you give a [ __ ]
that he committed crime maybe you should
give a [ __ ] if the last motherfucker's
kids committed crime maybe maybe just
maybe
hunter by gnome the laptop
the media lied they said he didn't own a
lamp the media never said that he didn't
own a laptop you dumb [ __ ]
never did they say that the new york
post they the media were trying to
suppress the story suppress what story
they still haven't charged him
he paid a back tax debt they're still
investigating him what the [ __ ] else do
you want
well secret service are protecting him
yeah that's because these [ __ ]
degenerates out there are acting like
hunter biden is the [ __ ] gonna bring
the world to the ground
and they have to protect the
[ __ ] or otherwise some [ __ ]
crazy right winger might just do
something huh
we're gonna watch
a [ __ ] sitting congresswoman from
michigan
stand on stage and say the words
weakness breeds aggression and the irony
just smacks her right in the [ __ ]
face like will smith did chris rock
the irony just
is dripping
off the podium
weakness breeds aggression
well
well miss mclean
there's only one party that is
aggressively against democracy in this
country
aggressively
so much so that they're willing to storm
a capitol building and murder
murder police officers
in the name of their aggression you
stupid [ __ ]
there are not two sides there both sides
are not the same in this country they're
not
they're not
and we're gonna get to the tweety tweets
and trendy trends i promise because we
had a lot of stuff to go through today
i mean there is just just a ton of [ __ ]
here
and we're gonna go we're pretty much
gonna do the [ __ ] list roundup round up
all the tweety tweets and attorney
trends all two hours today
there's just too much to get to not to
we get that twitter elon musk and
twitter of course is trending the secret
service is trending true social is
trending tucker carlson rupert murdoch
and fox news is trending
there was murder in bucha
ukraine
deutsche bank is trending
we have randy rainbow i have not watched
the video yet but we are gonna go watch
the new randy rainbow
video
uh of course the senate judiciary
committee is trending jennifer rubin is
trending because fascists are so upset
so upset
that jennifer rubin
jennifer rubin actually writes a decent
[ __ ] headline which she probably
didn't write the headline in the first
place but you know
they don't know how government works
they don't know how anything works how
would the [ __ ] they know that journalism
works
today is the anniversary of the
assassination of dr king as well so dr
king is training i'm sure there'll be a
million other things trending as we go
through the show but i do want to do
i do want to welcome everyone here
we broadcast live every single weekday
monday through friday
monday through friday it is a monday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch follow us
at toni michael's pod just go youtube
twitter twitch type in tony michael's
podcast tony michael's pod tony michaels
you will find us type in the tony
michaels or go to thetonymichaels.com
and find us there you also will find us
broadcasting on facebook
midas touch facebook page we broadcast
there every single weekday noon eastern
11 central nine pacific
every single weekday for two hours and
today we're gonna take two hours
and go through the shitless roundup
because boy with this trump rally we
have a lot of stuff to get to a lot of
stuff to watch a lot of people like oh
you're giving them oxygen no you have to
see
you want to see why you want to see why
dumb people do dumb things
do you want to see why do you want to
see what your [ __ ] neighbors and your
[ __ ] relatives are believing do you
want to see
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] walter masterson is he
was even stunned by the [ __ ] that
someone said about space force
it's incredible it's good stuff uh robin
here debbie is here kathy
is here forrest from facebook is here
amber from facebook is here paddy's here
uh jody from facebook lisa from facebook
crystal amber welcome all the new
facebook listeners
you guys are getting to be regulars here
i like to see that i love that i love
that mj is here this morning
kelly is here from facebook troy uh
yoda's here midas margie's here
well good morning good morning good
morning everyone's in the chat christina
is here
i'm sorry if i'm missing
there's so many of you i'm missing some
of you but thank you for joining us
every single weekday new nissan eleven
center right here on youtube twitter
twitch listen if you miss it it's okay
or if you missed part of the broadcast
it's okay it goes over to the youtube
channel it stays there it stays on the
minus touch facebook page
so make sure it stays on the twitch it
stays on the twitter so make sure to
subscribe
to the youtube channel that's most
important of all
and we don't miss any episodes or if you
do you can go re-watch them
also remember to follow us at
tonymichaelspot on twitter you can watch
all the broadcasts there if you want to
watch on twitter or on twitch
just type in tony michael's podcast
you will find us and then best part if
you want to watch over on youtube while
we're live you have the chance to do a
super chat
or get a super sticker you can support
the show that way we really appreciate
any support you guys give not just not
just monetarily if you give it in the
super chat but also
the likes shares
retweets whatever you do on facebook
i think it's shares right on facebook i
think so
you can like us
i don't know the follows the subscribers
we really thank you
we enjoy having you guys here with us
every single weekday live
so we can watch the comments i'm i'm
here by myself today so i will try to
keep track of the comments as we go
through the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends of the day
but go like and subscribe also if you
want to download the episodes that's
another way that you can
catch the episodes if you miss them live
is you can go download them on apple
spotify google any of the directories
that you have and while you're there
give us a five star review a good review
don't give us a bad review come on now
i mean you can say bad things about me
just you know give a five star review
we've had a few trolls over there give
us some some better views so go try to
even it out for me would you
even out the trolls i can't help but the
when the trolls go give reviews like you
can't there's nothing you do
they give reviews that's it that's it
so go help us out over there if you're
on any directory google spotify apple
download the previous episodes as well
as well
what a what a fantastic week we are
going to have this week
it is going to be a news field week i
have a feeling uh today is already
starting out that way it was a little
light on the load but now it's heavy
on the [ __ ] list roundup so let's find
out let's find out why elon musk wants
to own twitter
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
we are at the shitless roundup part of
the show which is gonna be
pretty much the entire show today
because we have so much [ __ ] done back
uh from the weekend you know monday
mornings are are tough that way
especially when there's especially when
there's a nazi rally over the i mean the
trump rally over the weekend
holy actual [ __ ] these people are amps
they've lost their [ __ ] minds they
have lost their minds good morning to
everyone everyone's still coming in
mayo's here
uh lisa from facebook says love your
podcast tony thank you very much
thank you very much
elizabeth is here from facebook daryl is
here
let's see who else do we have here oh my
gosh you guys are just rolling in here
rolling in here uh someone had a
question here that i want to answer
see if i can find it back
see this is the this is this is the
issue when i'm here by myself oh here we
go sharon from facebook says i would
like to know how to change trump trump
supporters minds
you mean change their minds like
like
a lobotomy or to change their minds of
they don't know what the hell they're
talking about and they're delusional
because i think i think you're talking
about the latter right
i don't know that you can change their
minds i don't know that you can change
their minds
i think all you can do is
try to hope that the the press in this
country
and the media in this country
decide to do the right thing and start
talking about democracy the way that
democracy needs to be talked about
what i mean by that is there's only one
party in this country
that is making sure to defend democracy
only one i mean there's a few from the
other side that are pretending
and i say pretending because they're not
they're not pretending all that well
i mean jesus christ everyone's like oh
liz cheney and adam kensinger are gonna
save us get the [ __ ] out of here those
two voted against voting rights
they they voted against the voting
rights bills get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
they're not defending anyone
you think you think that they're just
out to
to save democracy they're out to get
their party back is what they're out to
do
democracy is still
the enemy of the republican party
because at its core it's the voters it's
not the politicians the tail is wagging
the dog
come on now
go watch the trump rally we're going to
today on the [ __ ] list roundup we're
going to watch it
we're going to watch the trump rally
are parts of it i should say
but it's the tail that's wagging the dog
there was a there's a sitting united
states congresswoman from michigan
uh mclean i think is her last name
she stood on stage
stood on stage and said that trump
captured osama bin laden
and the crowd cheered yeah that's what
we want to hear
and of course that's what the [ __ ] they
want to hear
why not they want to hear lies they
don't want to hear the [ __ ] truth
so how do we change their minds i mean
the only way we change their minds is to
find a truth that they could adhere
to i think that's the hard truth in this
country that a lot of people haven't
come to grips with yet
i think that's the hard truth is that
it's a small percentage and i mean by
small i mean maybe 15 20 percent that
seems big but in the grand scheme of
things that's not huge but it's a large
number of people
it's a large number of people
who have been convinced that that
democracy is the enemy
democracy is going to take away their
privilege
because it will
it will they're [ __ ] correct
democracy
over time will take away their privilege
their white privilege it's gonna take it
away
as as people move more and more towards
equality and equity for everyone
it doesn't matter
skin color
gender
doesn't matter
who you love it doesn't matter as we
move closer and closer to equality and
equity for everyone not just citizens
not just white people everybody that's
in this country physically in this
country
citizen non-citizen
whatever religion you are as we move
closer to that because democracy moves
closer and closer to those things
over time
over time democracy delivers us
the equality and equity that that the
masses the people we the people desire
the freedom the liberty just like in the
in the
in the title opening the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty we strive for liberty that's
what we strive for
us pro-democracy people
are people who claim to be pro-democracy
i do believe
that
is the majority in this country
i mean regardless rather democracy
delivers your actual set of beliefs or
not i believe most people are
inclined to believe that democracy is
the correct way
of receiving the best result for
everyone
not autocracy regardless if it's on the
right or the left but boy is it easy to
buy into right wing authoritarianism
holy [ __ ]
especially especially for grievance to
white people
boy are we gonna watch a couple videos
of [ __ ]
some white grievance whoo
delusional type [ __ ]
i mean
literal space cadet stuff
holy moly
but that's why
that's why they don't like democracy
they don't want democracy because it
takes away
that's why putin's fighting democracy in
ukraine
democracies threatens to tear down his
authoritarian rule
and it's not just democracy in ukraine
it's democracy around the world
if the russian people start to believe
that their liberty will be delivered
with rights and freedoms that that
vladimir putin
withholds from them
they will topple his power his regime
that's why he has to spread chaos that's
why he has to spread lies
that's why he has to [ __ ] commit war
crimes
because without the chaos without
destroying democracy
vladimir putin is destroyed
because power is all these [ __ ]
people care about these authoritarian
types
most of them fascist but don't let it
get it twisted
the left has authoritarian
a little authoritarian ways too i mean
jesus christ
they want joe biden to hit a button and
prosecute donald trump today they want
merrick garland
to prosecute anyone and everyone that's
ever been within five feet of donald
trump
well that just is not how it [ __ ]
works in a democracy and it shouldn't be
our justice system should not just push
a button and destroy someone regardless
of how evil they are
because if they can do that to one
person they can do it to you
just like in the state of florida
where they sign the don't say gay bill
which we're gonna go through today i
guess that disney
is pulling a will smith
on ron desantis ron desantis i guess
said some [ __ ] that disney did not like
and they're gonna slap the [ __ ] at iran
desantis here
which i believe disney is the last is
the last enemy you want to have in
florida maybe not in the country but in
florida
baby
i don't know
i don't know if you're your biggest
on-the-ground employer one of the
biggest tourist attractions
in your entire state
if you want to really uh if you want to
already fight with them
as much as that sucks
it's a good thing disney is listening to
its employees because that's the most
important part here
is even inside disney the ceo is like oh
oh my employees want to make sure that i
stand up for equality and equity
hmm maybe i should do that
maybe i should do that and they are
on the same week that we see the first
amazon union
you think democracy doesn't work
you think democracy that's why they're
[ __ ] terrified that's why
authoritarians and people in power
especially white people who have
privilege are [ __ ] terrified
because they think somehow
somehow equity inequality is oppression
of them get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
i'm a white dude
as you can tell
been one my whole life
i have been the advantage of all the
privilege that comes with it every
[ __ ] last ounce of it
and i will use that privilege as other
white people should
to smash that privilege into oblivion
for equality and equity and i will
continue to do that
no matter what happens during the
midterms i will continue
to use my privilege to smash that
privilege into oblivion
for the sake of equality and equity for
everyone don't give a [ __ ] who you are
who you love i don't give a [ __ ] what
religion you adhere to or religion at
all i don't give a [ __ ]
you deserve liberty you deserve dignity
you deserve humanity
by god you're gonna get it
we're gonna fight for it so all the
pro-democracy people that should be your
stance because the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people
is not
liberty
learn it know it spread it
[ __ ] them
that's what someone says here on youtube
[ __ ] them longhorn says [ __ ] them you
goddamn right [ __ ] them [ __ ] them
go after them
pounce on them tear them apart tear them
the shreds
that's what we do all right let's get to
the timeline here
yeah we got a lot of stuff to get to we
got some time it's 20 we're holy moly
we're 28 minutes in the hole in the
first hour um
we're already at the bottom of the first
hour peeps
holy [ __ ]
i guess that's where the rant and raven
gets me okay
um here's the uh here's the tweet from
sam stein
uh earlier um
he's uh he's he's responding to um
marianna
levine here
graham says if republicans were in
charge of the committee and control of
the senate jackson would not have gotten
a
hearing now i don't
i don't view this as a threat from
lindsey graham right like i don't see
that this is a threat
i think this is lindsey graham saying
hey
hey all you trumpers out there if you
want to make sure
that we don't give a supreme court
qualified supreme court justice they're
due
well then put us in charge because you
know you know that of republicans in
charge they don't like [ __ ]
government they don't like democracy
they're going to do everything to stop
it everything to obstruct and sam
stein's dumb ass
both sides the issue
we are moving quickly towards a
situation where if the senate is
controlled of the opposite party of the
president or simply never
will simply never be a scotus
confirmation we may already be there
he's saying both sides are the same
they're not [ __ ] you sam stein
[ __ ] you
with your both sides and [ __ ] you want
to know what's wrong with the country do
you want to know sam stein why people
don't know what the [ __ ] the
unemployment rate is is because of dumb
stupid [ __ ] like this
dumb stupid [ __ ] narratives like this
that democrats wouldn't give a qualified
supreme court justice
their due in the senate
if they were in control if if a
president of the united states picked a
qualified person you are a [ __ ]
dumbass
and this is the stupid [ __ ] narrative
is the reason why people don't know what
the [ __ ] unemployment rate is they
have no [ __ ] clue
because you're like oh well
biden says it's 3.6 but what is it
really
i mean he's controlling gas prices right
sam stein
his his whole his whole numbers all his
polling is based on gas prices in the
economy and inflation right sam stein
it's as it's as if republicans and
democrats are exactly the same
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
your tweet sucks sam
your tweet sucks
and that's right we're gonna we're i'm
not just gonna call out republicans and
right wingers on this show
we're gonna go right after it
if you want to think that our democracy
is in peril well it is
and one of the reasons why is because
our media sucks they're not the enemy
they're not the enemy they're not our
enemy they just suck and it sucks to
suck
they need to clean up their act they're
their own worst enemy here
okay let's move on uh rupert murdoch is
a disease fox news is the symptom here's
another [ __ ] thing that they do
oh
fox news it's not
number one it should not be called fox
news
and no one should be referring to tucker
carlson as a journalist
[ __ ] that guy
[ __ ] tucker tucker sucks in the words of
george garland
listen this is the same stupid [ __ ]
of the bull sizing stuff and the [ __ ]
stupid ass media buys into this stuff
msnbc cnn they're like oh no we gotta
have we gotta have a bunch of fascists
on to spread their fascist putin
propaganda we gotta have them on because
that's fair and balanced because it's
the other side deserves to have their no
no the other side does not need to go on
the news and spread lies
you as a journalist do not have to
welcome on someone who's going to spread
lies
no matter what side they're [ __ ] on
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
and fox news
is a symptom of the disease that is
rupert murdoch
that's right rupert murdoch is the
disease
don't believe me elon musk just bought
over nine percent of twitter
some news
um zelinski president zalinski of
ukraine invites um angela merkel to buka
to see the results of year-long
concessions to russia
he's claiming
that
merkel needs to come see the torture
ukraines with her her own eyes
because their concession and not
welcoming um ukraine into
nato that's the result that the putin's
aggression
is a result of them not being part of
nato that's the news coming out of kiev
this morning
um
uh jennifer rubin's
in the in the trends or was i don't know
she still is fascist big mad jennifer
rubin doesn't cow towel to trump nazis
just because jennifer rubin doesn't
[ __ ]
you know bow down to the trumpers at the
trump rally and tell them what they want
to hear just because the tail doesn't
wag her dog she's the enemy i mean
jennifer rubin has a lot of really bad
takes folks
a real and a lot but just because she
doesn't count out to the nazis get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
okay time for breakfast elon musk eat
the rich now we're on the elon musk
topic already i guess elon musk bought
over nine percent it's like 9.2 i think
i think it makes him the largest
shareholder of twitter now i think this
is the case
now i know i don't know if that's good
or bad
look i really don't know i mean i guess
time will tell
i mean elon musk claims that he wants to
to be more for freedom of speech or
whatever which you know probably makes
it to where there's a hell of a lot more
troll farms
on twitter and he probably will welcome
the troll farms i mean he loves crypto
so he loves the trolls anyways
now my question is is
is he going to require people to use his
form of currency
to buy and sell things you know
advertising that sort of thing
[Music]
mayo says who else agrees that there's
nothing left
of the republican party but traitors and
terrorists well
pretty god damn close if we're not there
already
just watch some of these trump rally
clips we're going to get to it i promise
i promise it's in the timeline here oh
here
uh tiktok banned this video
uh i was on uh stuttering john melendez
uh podcast stunner and gone podcast
last week i believe it was a wednesday
or thursday i believe
i remember the day i was on there one
day last week
with uh richard ojeda
and at one point
john and i were talking about the don't
say gay bill
and i said that the gqp is obsessed with
genitalia because they are they're
absolutely [ __ ] obsessed with
genitalia they're [ __ ] weirdos
these [ __ ] people that go to these
nazi rallies these trump rallies these
queuing honors they are absolutely
obsessed
with child porn and genitalia obsessed
with it they can't stop thinking about
it
and they can't stop thinking about
children's sexuality which i don't even
understand what the [ __ ] that has to do
with anything with gender now john john
and i were talking about
um the don't say gay bill and i said
this and and
let me let me play it and then we'll
talk about it what the bill actually
does is make it to where a kindergartner
who has two moms
right who has two moms they don't get to
say that they have two moms right and
somehow that's sexualizing something
which gender is not sexualizing anything
in this country that's such a bunch of
[ __ ] because you get a white dude like
me and a white woman like my wife and
they're christian and they're running
around
and their and their husband and wife
they're no one says anything about sex
about that relationship but you get you
get a gay person man and a man a woman
and a woman are trans man and a man oh
there it's all sexualized and these
[ __ ] weirdos are absolutely obsessed
with other people's gender other
people's sexuality and the weirdest part
about it all
is they're completely obsessed with
other people's genitalia and bathrooms i
have never [ __ ] went into a bathroom
and and thought about someone else's
genitalia what are you weirdos doing
what are you doing i mean that's a great
point i i don't even yeah i don't
i can give a frog's bad ass if i'm
taking a piss and and there's a girl
you know
taking a piss in the store what the hell
do i care
it really is uh
weird that they are so focused on other
people's genitalian bathrooms i really i
never in my life went into a bathroom
and had my mind on someone else's
genitalia i go in i take a piss i take a
[ __ ] and i get the hell out of there i
don't understand why they're so focused
on other what's in other people's pants
it is very telling it's very telling and
they're very obsessed with children's
sexuality i mean they are obsessed with
it not their gender they're obsessed
with their sexuality
like they want to make it about gender
but gender has nothing to do with sex
nothing not a goddamn thing i mean yeah
gender and sex those there is a
definition of the word sex that you know
resembles gender but that doesn't mean
gender has anything to do with the other
definition of sex
nothing to do with it
even who you love doesn't necessarily
have anything to do with sex
just because a man loves a man doesn't
mean and they're gay doesn't mean it has
anything to do with sex i mean maybe at
some point it does but that doesn't mean
that's the main focus
they don't understand it though because
they don't care and understand it
because those people are the others and
they're weird and we need to get rid of
them because they don't fit in my little
nice little box that makes me feel
comfortable
[ __ ] weirdos thinking about other
people's genitalia now here's the point
i posted that video um
on
i posted on instagram not this one
specific i mean same clip
just uh i didn't make it the vertical i
made it the the normal sh that what it
looked like on the show but i put this
on tick tock so i kind of had to you
know edit it a bit
that's why it looks like this but the
point is this tic-tac took it down for
hate speech now i'm sure someone
reported it for [ __ ] hate speech
i'm sure
hate speech that's what they reported
bill actually does and i think it's
because they that they were mad
that you know i was spot on
they're weirdos and they're obsessed
with genitalia oh you don't call me a
weirdo and reported it right
here's the great part is that tick-tock
i i appealed it and tic-tac has has put
the video back up they found that there
was no hate speech in it of course
because there isn't any hate speech in
it it's the exact opposite of hate
speech i'm advocating for people
who are getting their liberty taken away
from them in florida
their liberty to be who they are or
their liberty to say who their parents
are
literally this build they're like oh
it doesn't read it's a seven page bill
[ __ ] read the seven pages it
doesn't say don't say gay so they're mad
the biggest thing they're mad about
about this bill republic nazis nazis
like ron desantis is a [ __ ] nazi he's
a [ __ ] nazi the reason why they're so
these bigots are so [ __ ] upset
about this bill is because democrats won
the messaging
they're like oh it's it's not a don't
say gay bill it doesn't say that
it talks about the sexuality of
kindergarten yeah you wrote the bill
about the sexual the sexuality of
kindergartners not a democrat democrat
had nothing to do
with [ __ ] sexualizing
kindergartners through third graders you
did that by saying gender has something
to do with sexuality
look i'm a parent i have two kids
i helped raise two kids
and any parent out there that has little
kids like
under the age of
five six years old
there is a point where that little kid
asked about genitalia they ask about it
they ask
you you don't have to like tell them you
don't have to like like they're [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] smart enough to
understand
that they have genitalia they don't know
what it is
they have no clue they're little kids
they don't know
and that's why when you're in a
situation where i don't know
maybe an educational situation
like in a school when you're educating
someone and they asked a question like
that
maybe it'd be a good time to educate
them you dumb [ __ ] and you
weirdos thinking that genitalia or your
gender has anything to do with sexuality
that's on you [ __ ] weirdos that's on
you [ __ ] weirdos you're the ones who
are completely focused
on a [ __ ] kindergartener sexuality
their gender listen weirdos listen you
gqp nazi let's go brandon weirdos
gender
gender has nothing
not a goddamn thing to do
with your sexuality
not a goddamn thing
you let me prove it to you
there are and listen up
listen up you [ __ ] gq peers
you let's go brandon nazis
ron desantis fascist
a trans man
a trans man
can be in love
with a man
got it
got it it has nothing gender has nothing
to do with sexuality you think it does
because you're a [ __ ] weirdo
you are a [ __ ] weirdo stop stop
worrying about other people's genitalia
when you go in the bathroom
worry about getting your [ __ ] done
washing your [ __ ] hands because
you're nasty and getting the [ __ ] out of
there please stay the [ __ ] out of the
bathroom if you can't focus on anything
but other people's genitalia okay let's
move on
we'll get back to ron desantis i'm
[ __ ] sure of it okay here we are
we're at some of the trump rally [ __ ]
let's go back to tom tom powell is uh
now you guys know him from tick tock
he's actually was on the show um last
year tom was a guest on the show
tom's got a lot of
good takes over on the tiki talks
he's here on
on on on the tw tweety tweets here
i posted this video of this guy with
this vist
and let's watch the video then we'll go
to tom's post
um
this guy's a weirdo by the way it's
really [ __ ] weird this is uh this is
one of the guys that trump has pointed
out
in his uh in his rally speeches or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
when he's when he's howling himself hal
hitler i mean hal trump i mean whatever
the hell they do
so he knows our group from there we just
grow you know trump security uh trump
patch here the deplorables jexic um
ashley babbitt uh you know uh bikers uh
against human trafficking it's just a
lot of patches we gain over the time and
we want to represent different groups he
recognizes you when you when he sees you
i do know that for a fact you guys are
he knows he knows who we are he points
right out at us we're always front row
he he knows who we are so
we're tremendously grateful for that you
know he he recognizes loyalty and he
gives it back you know just having trump
acknowledge me last week and take a
personal picture with me was like almost
a dream come true it was a dream come
true and i'm forever grateful so here
here you have this let's go brandon nazi
and i know he's a let's go brand nazis
he's got it written on his [ __ ]
forehead that says let's go brandon
you remember the nazis down in florida
held up the let's go brandon
um
banners with the the nazis
with the swastikas so this this is one
of those guys
if you go back here and look at this
video
he's got all these [ __ ] trump you
know patches or whatever this is [ __ ]
here's what i said
i see
i think some people believe this i said
i have a shitload of i love our i heart
i should say i have a shitload of i
heart biden patches on my letter vest
this isn't weird at all oh holy [ __ ]
this is super [ __ ] cringy super
[ __ ] weird it's super [ __ ] culty
super [ __ ] culty
right
i want to represent all these cults all
these groups that are inside the trump
cult inside the q anon
if you notice a couple things about this
video number one this guy has desecrated
the american flag which they all do
they all do he's desecrated in a couple
different ways number one
he's desecrated by basically making a
shirt into it now i don't always i don't
believe this [ __ ] right like i i think
you can make a shirt you can make
underwear it's your freedom to desecrate
the flag i really do i think i think our
soldiers fought for your right to
desecrate the flag burn the flag wipe
your ass with the flag if you want
that's your [ __ ] liberty that is your
freedom you can protest by making a
shirt out of it by making underwear out
of it putting it on a swimsuit whatever
you want to do
but they tend to have the opposite
[ __ ] view of most of this [ __ ] so i'm
assuming this guy
would you talk about cal and kaepernick
this guy black ah that [ __ ]
desecrating our flag while he's wearing
a [ __ ] desecrated flag on his [ __ ]
back the other desecration that he has
of the flag is the blackout flag here on
his vest
so [ __ ] all over the american flag
but again you bring up colin kaepernick
you know he's a black dude who kneeled
during a football game to bring
solidarity to black men and black people
being killed by police officers he's
desecrating the flag because he was
kneeling in protest
i'm guarantee it
saying wearing a [ __ ] shirt that's
made out of american flag or what is
trying to appear to be an american flag
desecrating it would say that [ __ ] now
again i i think it's this guy's freedom
to do this stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] i think
it's his liberty and his freedom to be
dumb to be ignorant to be delusional
to be really [ __ ] stupid this is your
liberty this is what you have the other
thing about this video if you look at it
really close
right
you would think this was like a gotcha
type [ __ ] where you would show like
someone would you know like walter
matterson or the good liars or jordan
klepper trying to do the gotcha stuff
nope that's not this is on rsbn
this is the [ __ ] trump propaganda
news network folks
that they're playing this [ __ ] in
washington michigan holy [ __ ]
this isn't some kind of gotcha type [ __ ]
let's go to what tom powell jr said of
my tweet of this
video
he says the trump cult
he's puzzled with a q by the way
is a never-ending parade of inbred
cousin [ __ ]
all trying to out do one another and the
who can kiss the dear leaders
the best ass i say department
hey wish easy writer i think he's saying
that this guy this is the wish.com
easywriter you're in a cult seek help
i completely agree it is a [ __ ] cult
and we're gonna see some more clips that
gives us that evidence and that proof oh
here's the uh here's the sam stein
article
a shocking data point
this is the sam sam stein article from
politico
about the unemployment rate instead of
this [ __ ] reporting about the
unemployment rate to make sure the
american people know
this is what he's reporting here's the
headline look at it
why biden's job numbers isn't
translating
why do the american people not know why
gi
what
biden's job numbers are it's almost like
there's someone at politico that could
write stories
so the american people know about the
unemployment rate
it's almost like there's someone there's
not but it's almost like there's someone
sam stein a shocking data point that
explains much of biden's political
troubles biden does not have political
trouble folks
the economy is doing well yes there's
inflation yes that the oil companies are
gouging you and so are corporations but
that's not biden's political trouble
the only reason why is biden's political
trouble is because people are [ __ ]
delusional
to think that joe biden has the ability
to control gas prices or inflation
or really has the ability has an
unemployment button on his desk but if
he does have an unemployment button on
his desk he's [ __ ] using it
he's [ __ ] using it
because sam goes on to say here more
people think jobs have been lost over
the last year 37 percent of people think
that more jobs have been lost
then think who
they've been gained 28
so what he's saying here is 28 of people
think
that there's been a job gain
and 37 percent think that there's been a
job loss
well this is just even even if these
people actually believe this which i'm
not sure if that's the truth it is a
[ __ ] poll
it is a poll
but even if that's the truth
if that's the truth is it biden's fault
is is it biden's fault
because biden doesn't come out every day
and go well you know
my unemployment numbers are down but
it's always you know republicans they do
a good job we do a good job you know
there's both sides to this thing and
really on no
no
no they just he gets up in the morning
joe biden gets up in the morning puts
his [ __ ] shoes on and does his
[ __ ] job you don't sam stein because
sam stein here says unemployment is 3.6
oh
how in the world how in the world could
anyone believe
that the unemployment is anything but
3.6
i mean it's not like i'm on a daily
doing my job to make sure everyone knows
sam
i like you buddy i do i actually like
sam stein i think sam stein is a smart
dude
this is not a smart take
your tweet
[ __ ] sucks sam
and so does your work
get off your ass and do your [ __ ] job
the the free press is not the enemy of
the people
it's its own worst enemy that's the
problem
keith olbermann here he says
maybe sam
maybe sam because politico is among many
outlets that are both sizing democracy
to death there you go
yep that's it see
even even keith olbermann
agrees
i mean how could you not how could you
not
with this
this dribble
this dribble oh my god my job is to make
sure the american people know the
unemployment rate is 3.6 and they don't
know because i'm not doing my job what's
the problem
the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] get
your [ __ ] together american media uh
oh here's some more this isn't trump
rally [ __ ] but these people have
appeared at a trump rally before and i'm
not just talking about diamond and silk
but i'm also talking about steve king um
i don't want to play all this i just
want to play about
i just want to play the first part
because uh diamond and silk here they
act like they don't know who madison
gothard is this is [ __ ] fabulous they
they pretend like they've never met the
[ __ ]
don't know who he is never met the
[ __ ] never heard of him damn no
what's his name
just listen i just heard something she
just heard you talk about it y'all yeah
the later of the week but uh-huh
something better get your phone out what
is his name yeah you gotta look up his
name what's that guy's name what's that
nazi congressman's name that we love all
the [ __ ] that he says that we love and
how he says it and how we love how he
says it
what's his name what's that what's that
little that little roll around nazi's
name i think it i i don't call him this
but some people call him sittler what's
his name diamond and silk
he's co he's a congressman yeah
he's not mad he's a congressman from
right here
thought caught thorn hawthorne caught
though that's his name get the [ __ ] out
of here like these two don't know what
the [ __ ] his name is come on
are we supposed to believe that [ __ ]
he's just a coffee boy now
i said they don't know madison author in
this game they'll [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ] i need to put that on t-shirts
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
all right we got a space cadet here uh
walter reposted this video um he says
i've heard every stupid maga now we've
interviewed uh walter before
and he's talked about a lot of these
trump rallies he said i've heard every
stupid manga theory but this one is too
good
i need to start asking magas
about space force i've never heard this
either and they now i've had some family
um that have fallen to this q anon [ __ ]
um yeah hard
and they they they've said some of the
[ __ ] that you've seen in the genie
jeannie thomas uh text messages
to mark meadows you know what i'm
talking about where they thought he's
talking about military tribunals and all
kinds of weird ass [ __ ]
and sidney powell and the kraken all
kinds of weird ass [ __ ] [ __ ] how joe
biden isn't actually the president all
kinds of wackadoo [ __ ]
but this i have never heard this
i've heard the jfk [ __ ] and all that
stuff i have never heard
i have never heard what this
bonehead is about to say
up here
they literally
the night of the election
they literally literally watched the
election be stolen
they know they watermark the ballots
they know exactly what happened with
every ballot they know what fake ballots
all right they saw they knew the
election switches they know what
countries were involved
they know they followed the money they
know what every politician
that's been paid off they know yeah
there's um there was 260 000
269 000
uh sealed indictments but i think it
might even be up to 500 000 sealed
indictments
and i believe that we're going to have
an emergency broadcast and the military
is going to come in with martial law
and
we are going to be shown eight hours on
eight hours off of videos for seven days
the world and they're gonna be showing
us taped
uh tribunals
tape confessions
and
the world is going to be awakened what's
really going on with the deep state [ __ ]
the deep state that's another one listen
to the very beginning again listen what
she says in the very beginning the
election i believe was stolen
but we know that
space force has it all trump space force
has it all
i don't know if it's i don't know if
it's because trump
uh came up with space force that's why
they think that i'm not real sure if
they really think that then why aren't
they getting vaccinated trump you know
invented the vaccine right i said
i said space cadet
like literally holy [ __ ]
you people are you people are what kind
of drugs are these people on
that's what i want to know what kind of
drugs are you on jesus [ __ ] christ
share would you please
god damn this is absolutely batshit
crazy
absolutely 100
that [ __ ] crazy
now again
let me remove the banner here so you can
see
this is very [ __ ] important this
isn't you know walter reposted this and
he said he's going to start asking about
this
you know he does the videos where he
asks people at rallies and they say some
crazy ass [ __ ] to him right they say
some crazy ass [ __ ] and he captures it
on camera because it's like holy [ __ ]
these people are weird they're dumb
they're delusional what the [ __ ] is
going on
but this is not a gotcha type thing
this is rsbn this is the trump
propaganda network
and they're like yeah let's pump this
into the ether
let's pump this into the minds of the
people who are watching
so here's the scary part not that this
[ __ ] person believe cause come on
you're telling me
you're telling me that that that q anon
karen here queuing on karen here in line
with the trump rally she knows what
space force knows but no one else knows
it get the [ __ ] out of here with that
[ __ ]
but these people believe this stuff
because they're like yeah what did you
see the lady on the television
they interviewed her by god they
interviewed her and she said that space
force
was going to save us all from the from
the blood-sucking cabal
the george soros blood-sucking common
cabal
listen
george soros is not paying i wish he was
but he's not he's not paying us he's not
paying a [ __ ] dime he's a deadbeat if
he's if he's actually paying part of the
cabal he's not paying us
but this lady
is queuing on karen here
is running around
saying this [ __ ] but the weirdest part
is that they're airing it
they're airing this stupidity as if it's
[ __ ] real
right
don't
don't you see how this has happened
can't you figure out how look humans
humans do this thing
where they have preconceived notions
they have you know they're predisposed
to certain positions
you know based on your experience right
and and most the time your experiences
your religion your education your
upbringing
there's a lot of things that go into
each individual person's experience
that's why we have to give everyone
liberty right that's the purpose is
because everyone's experience is
different
that's why we must extend them liberty
so that their experience can dictate
what their ideas
their religion is what their beliefs are
that's why we have to extend them that
liberty
right even even q anon karen here
deserves liberty
even though she doesn't know what it is
or what to do with it she deserves it
she's a human
she's in america
we have to give her liberty
whoosh even though what she needs is
some [ __ ] mental health
badly badly needs mental health
but here's the thing humans are
predisposed to believe the things
that back up their position right
so what does that mean
well that means that q anon karen here
has been predisposed to absolutely hate
anything that's not donald trump
and anything that she reads listens to
or devours
any content that she
indulges in
as long as it backs up that ultimate
root belief well she's gonna believe it
obviously
no [ __ ] rational human being would
think
that they are privy to information that
the space force is privy to where
they're gonna hold military tribunals
and they're gonna have tape confessions
and they're gonna what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
you think you think that [ __ ] was posted
on facebook you are a dumb [ __ ]
if you think if space force really does
have what space cadet karen here says
they have
they're not gonna broadcast that [ __ ] on
facebook dummy
they're not i mean merrick garland the
entire half the country is pissed off at
merrick garland because he won't show
his cards of how he's going to prosecute
trump
well not him specifically the department
of justice
they're going to folks
mark my words mark it down i said it
they're going to prosecute trump
and his family
yes for crimes that he's committed
but he's not going to show his cards
neither would space force really i mean
honestly if you believe this [ __ ] that
space war somehow knew that joe biden
stole the election and somehow there's
going to be [ __ ] deep confessions or
whatever this whatever this nut bag is
[ __ ] talking about here
if you really believe that if you
thought that [ __ ] was true
they wouldn't show you their cards on
facebook dummy
come on
but it's a cult
it's a [ __ ] cult
and the problem is is the fascist like
ron desantis
donald trump mike flynn
jenny thomas are leading these [ __ ]
people around
and they're still hurting up like sheep
to go listen to this dribble
and it is drivel
100 full stop it's dribble
because here is the thing let me show
you another clip from this rally
uh well that's one of them
this one here this one's the most
important one
this here is uh
she is a congresswoman her name is lisa
mclean
she's a representative of michigan's
10th district you can see it right here
again
this is not some gotcha news network or
cnn or msnbc whatever the [ __ ] this is
trump propaganda news network this is
fascist traitor tv as it were
listen to what this [ __ ] bonehead
says
about osama bin laden
but then listen to the cr
well first off she says a lot of [ __ ]
lies
the osama bin laden one was really
[ __ ] weird
but the other one she says is there
wasn't a war during trump but just
listen well president trump was in
office
we didn't have a war there was no war
why president trump was in office not
one
not like the [ __ ] war that they
bitched that joe biden got out of
because joe biden's term was after
trump's term
so it's almost like
lisa mclean here believes delusionally
that the afghanistan war stopped the
minute trump became president and then
started right back up the minute he
wasn't
this is really [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
i mean they blame joe biden
on the daily
that he botched
trump's plan to exit afghanistan
literally trump's administration and
trump's dod came up with the plan to
exit afghanistan
joe biden had to execute that plan
didn't have much of a choice they didn't
give him much of a choice to be honest
with you
the dod and trump administration didn't
give him much of a choice he had to undo
it because of deals that the trump
administration made with the taliban
with their secretary of state
mike pompeo made deals with the taliban
to take over afghanistan
biden didn't have much of a choice in
that deal he became president he had to
execute the deal they had made america
us our government our state department
made
our dod
the commander-in-chief is not an
authoritarian dictator he doesn't just
get to say whatever the [ __ ] he wants
and do whatever the [ __ ] he wants even
if these trumpers believe that
and you shouldn't believe it either
frankly we should take some power away
from the president i don't care if it's
jill biden donald trump or whoever
hillary clinton kamala harris whoever
the [ __ ] the president is we need to
take more power away from we need to get
more
power back into the hands of congress to
be frank
but here's the point
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is standing on stage
in front of a crowd of people saying
that president trump there was no war
while he was president
holy actual [ __ ]
i mean this isn't this isn't this isn't
like some kind of [ __ ]
weird ass
where we may have been in war we may not
we were in a [ __ ] war in afghanistan
had been
since 9 11 everyone well not everyone
that not the american people didn't feel
this
they really didn't understand that we
were in a war in afghanistan still until
we exited
and
unfortunately 13 soldiers
lost their lives in the exit of
afghanistan only proving that we needed
to exit afghanistan even more
those 13 soldiers those 13 brave
soldiers lost their lives defending
the people who were exiting afghanistan
doing their jobs defending those people
americans afghanis
refugees
they were defending them from the enemy
the taliban
which the trump administration did a
deal with
to take over afghanistan
once we exited
which they put that plan into place
before joe biden became president which
forced him to do it
and they complained about it you
remember oh my god joe biden [ __ ] that
up he did this he did that he [ __ ]
this up he [ __ ] that up
and i said back then i said last i said
last year go back and listen to the tape
i said no one will [ __ ] remember that
joe biden exited afghanistan and here we
are
here we are
with the q and honor here lisa mclean
this delusional stupid idiot
standing on stage not even knowing we
were in the war in afghanistan forget
about blaming joe biden forget about
knowing that joe biden is the one who
exited
the [ __ ] war and they were gonna
blame it on him even though it was
trump's [ __ ] exit plan
and they did the best they could and
frankly
it was the most successful
moving of of refugees and human beings
out of a conflict that there ever was
the fastest
yeah there was a lot of problems with it
but a shitty plan blings brings
logistical problems but they wanted to
blame everything on biden
but my point last year was that these
people won't even [ __ ] remember there
was a war that joe biden exit
here is lisa mclean not even [ __ ]
knowing she's she's an elected official
folks this is not an audience member
this is not someone testing the mic
she is elected to make decisions for me
and you
more specifically
the folks in michigan's ten
she gets to make decisions
that affect their liberty
and she doesn't even know that we were
in a war with afghanistan while trump
was president let's get to some more
crazy ass [ __ ]
and i think he made three piece treaties
i think he made three pieced tree what
the [ __ ] does that mean what is a
three-piece treaty number one is this
like a
a three-piece chicken dinner i don't
know i know what the [ __ ] that means but
he did not make three peace treaties
dumbass
and then
yeah they cheer
they cheer for the that that there was
no war and there was peace treaties
here's where the weird ass [ __ ] comes in
after they cheer
listen what she says about osama bin
laden caught osama osama bin laden
and solamani
al-baghdadi
he caught osama bin laden look
i am old enough to remember like i'm old
enough to remember
who the president
the vice president and the secretary of
state were in 2011.
if you rewind the clock
and you try to think who was the
president of the united states who is
the vice president united states and who
was the secretary of state
in 2011.
if you're correct if you do your math
right you know you might have to count
on your [ __ ] fingers and your toes
here
if you remember that was obama's first
term
in office
barack
hussein obama as they say
was president in 2011.
his vice president
was joseph biden our current president
the secretary of state at the time
was hillary rodham clinton
who is their arch nemesis i mean other
than hunter biden's laptop it is
questionable rather hillary clinton's
emails or hunter binds laptop is more of
an enemy to the right right now
i mean there's no better ally that they
have than putin because putin's enemy is
hunter biden's laptop and hillary
clinton's emails apparently too
other than all the innocent murdering
that he's of women and children that
he's doing in ukraine those are his
mortal enemies
as well those innocent people that are
being murdered in the streets
but in 2011 in barack obama's first term
not a second
if you remember the election if you do
your math the election was in 2012
barack obama ran against mitt romney
remember mitt romney ran on the lie that
barack obama said if you got a business
you didn't build that
they ran on that line they lost
but that was it was before then because
barack obama ran on that he captured
osama bin laden that was one of the
[ __ ] things he's like yeah i'm tough
on terrorism
i mean i remember that night i remember
people in the streets were cheering
americans were cheering even people who
did not like barack obama specifically
were cheering at barack obama
ordered the capture
of osama bin laden
with seal team six we all remember this
we remember the story
it's not complicated to know the simple
facts
but here lisa mclean doesn't know there
is a war in afghanistan
doesn't know which president was
president in 2011 either that or she
doesn't [ __ ] know who captured osama
bin laden
she's been reading way too much facebook
representative lisa mclean
maybe that is one thing that we need to
legislate
is that these [ __ ] congress people
stay the [ __ ]
off facebook let's listen to what else
this dumb [ __ ] says and this president
is weak
and i'll tell you weakness breeds
aggression
okay we get to the best part about it
all this is what i was talking about
earlier where the irony smacks this dumb
[ __ ] in the face
weakness breeds aggression
there's only one [ __ ] party in this
country only one that is aggressive
aggressively trying to tear down our
democracy
only one you're still holding nazi
rallies for a guy who lost
you're still you're still perpetuating
this america first save america [ __ ]
where you want to tear down our
constitution where you drove your your
[ __ ] followers to the united states
capital to try to tear up our
constitution and tear down our
government
that's what you did
your side the republican party is a
bunch of [ __ ] traitors and trees and
his bastards
only one is anti-democracy in this
country only one
only one
and there's only one pro-democracy party
anymore
i mean i wish there was two i wish the
republicans still had some sort of
pro-democracy vein inside of them but it
doesn't exist
it doesn't exist because the fascists
have taken over
and they've driven everyone out of the
party that either won't
won't be fascist or at least won't
adhere to their fascist little lies
but it really is let me let me go back
to it sorry here it really is [ __ ]
weird
that she says
weakness breeds aggression because trump
is weak
you manga fascist
are weak you let's go brandon nazis are
weak
and that's what's breeding your
aggression
you stupid [ __ ]
you're weak and that's what's breeding
your aggression because i agree with her
weakness does breed aggression
weakness does breed aggression and boy
do they have a [ __ ] ton of it
weakness and aggression
i'm sure she'll make an appearance on
bonehead of the week let's see here
[Music]
let's go to the tweet tweets and trendy
trends
finally make it there i want to go see
um let's listen in on a little bit of
the uh
the hearing
let's see if we can
listen in on the hearing of judge brown
jackson
uh did it just end did we just
i want to see if there's um
any kind of news being made out of
that hearing
it says it's live
um
looks like that hearing is ended let's
go to uh you know what let's go to
c-span see if we can see the um
see some of that video
we're seeing because i guess lindsey
graham talked about a lot of
a lot of nonsense
we're gonna go to c-span and see if we
can
figure this out
uh but apparently lindsey graham said
this morning
if katangi brown jackson oh here here we
go
let's um
let's remove
this one we're gonna go to a different
um screen here
and looks like um
looks like they're convening maybe but
let's let's uh let's listen in
on the hearing here
see if we can turn
oh okay
let's listen in for just a bit
oh and then we'll uh
we'll come right back
is
[Music]
we were just
yes
[Music]
[Music]
so it looks like they're going to be uh
voting this afternoon on the nomination
doesn't look like anything appear going
to be happening uh let's um let's go
back to the tweety tweets and trendy
trends
as we keep an eye on the situation
we'll keep this window open
um and see if we can
continue
to see what would bring about
from the hearing
of judge brown jackson
uh let's go back to the tweety tweets
and the trendy trends
share that
screen again there we are okay
let's go
there we go okay
so we will keep an eye on the
on the hearing here if it readjourns um
see if there's any uh news out of it it
looks like um
ted cruz has a clip here let's watch
some
let's watch some nonsense from ted cruz
not a single
republican senator asked her about her
high school yearbook
engaged in the kind of personal slanders
that democrats have made a business
about
if the questions were hard it is because
her record
is at the extreme
there have been 115 men and women who
have served on the supreme court if
judge jackson is confirmed i believe she
will prove to be
the most extreme and the furthest left
justice ever to serve on the united
states supreme court good [ __ ] you
good i hope she's the leftist of the
left of the left
and we should have more like her dumb
[ __ ]
because the reason why ted cruz you
can't ask
katanji brown jackson about some dumb
[ __ ] stupid ass
some dumb [ __ ] stupid ass yearbook
is because it doesn't exist
it doesn't exist you can't question
katanji brown jackson
about sexual assault
because it doesn't exist
you cannot question kbj judge brown
jackson
about
hiding her bigotry behind her religious
dogma
because it doesn't exist
the only thing you got ted cruz
is to yammer on and on and on
about child porn
and the only reason why you get the
yammer on and on and on about child porn
is because katangi brown jackson is
qualified to be a [ __ ] federal judge
that's what she is and she has more
[ __ ] experience
in in the sentences that she has handed
down
to criminal convictions in this country
that she has overseen
then the last three justices have
combined you dumb [ __ ]
and when you are a federal judge and
you're qualified to be a federal judge
ted [ __ ] cruz who will never be a
[ __ ] federal judge by the way
he only wishes he would be
the reason why
that kbj
is qualified
to be a federal judge to be a supreme
court justice
is because she is a black woman
and i don't mean because
she's a black woman i mean because she
is a black woman and she's had to do the
things that black women have to do in
this country
she didn't get where she's at because
she's a black woman
she got where she's at because she's had
to work 10 times harder than any other
[ __ ] out there because she is a
black woman
got it do you think that black women in
this country their most highly educated
demographic
of any other group in this country
because they're they're just black women
no
no it's because they're black women they
have to work so [ __ ] hard way [ __ ]
harder than any guy that looks like me
would or brett kavanaugh
or amy coney barrett or neil gorsuch for
that matter
way [ __ ] harder
have to exert a hundred times more
energy
into her profession and her job
her career and her passion
that's why you bring up child porn
is because katangi brown jackson is
qualified to be a federal judge and
because of that reason because she
worked so [ __ ] hard because she
became a federal judge dumb [ __ ]
she had to sentence people who did
crimes that had to do with child porn
and because katangi brown jackson is
[ __ ] qualified to be a federal judge
and she's the most qualified person to
ever sit in the seat that you're talking
about there you you [ __ ]
nut sack
it's because she works so hard
and so diligently
to be a justice
to hand down justice according to the
law
she explained to you ted cruz
and tom cotton and josh holly
talking about obsessed with porn
josh holly
she explained to you several times what
sentencing guidelines are and how they
work
she even like you know explained it as
if a five-year-old was listening
obviously needed explain to you like a
five-year-old needs explaining
but here's the thing
the reason why you keep bringing up
child porn
is because it's the only thing you got
and it's not even a thing you got and
the reason why it's not a thing you got
is because you voted
the senate voted
almost unanimously to make katanji brown
jackson a federal judge to make those
decisions you dumb [ __ ]
and not only that you've elected
or excuse me you have voted for
federal judges that came before you that
were
placed there by a republican nomination
not a democratic nomination
who were lighter on the sentencing of
the same child pornographers
as you're saying tangie brown jackson
was light on get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
this is a perfect example
right here this little clip with ted
cruz sam stein if you want one if you
need one sam if you want to write a
story on one
here's your story about how both sides
are not the same
maybe people will start listening when
you talk about the unemployment rate
being 3.6 percent
here is a perfect example of how both
parties are not the same
judge brown jackson
that is the perfect example
ted cruz is whining and complaining that
he can't question
katangi brown jackson's yearbook he
there's no question that he can draw
from her yearbook and there's no
question he can draw from her religious
dogma and her hiding her bigotry behind
it
and there's no question that they can
ask about sexual allegations against kbj
it's ridiculous that judge brown jackson
does not have sexual assault charges
against her that i can ask about it's
[ __ ] ridiculous it's ridiculous that
she didn't write some
bonehead ass [ __ ] in her high school
yearbook that i cannot question her
about
it is [ __ ] ridiculous that she
doesn't hide her bigotry behind her
religious dogma like all republicans do
that way i can ask her about it
there you go sam stein that's the
difference
there's the difference in the two
parties
there's your [ __ ] difference it's
glaring
it's glaring not only is katangi brown
jackson the most liberal judge ever in
the history of judges ever and ever and
ever never
which i hope she is
i hope she is and i hope she spreads it
around in that court i hope it's
contagious
[ __ ] them
she is the most qualified
person that has ever sat in the seat to
be nominated
for a supreme court seat and i'm not
just saying that because she's a black
woman i'm saying it because
she's a black woman
because of this she's had to work so
hard
she's had to do so much
way harder than anyone else will ever
dream of working to get where she is
so think about that for a second
think about the both sides argument well
both sides i mean i mean
amy coney bear she was qualified
uh
she was quo i mean
you know
kinda
qualified
no
not even [ __ ] close
not even close
the reason why you're bitching and
moaning and complaining about not being
able to attack
kbj on sexual assault charges
because brett kavanaugh had assault
allegations against him hmm
that's not a glaring obvious difference
about kbj other than she's not an
accused sexual assaulter that
republicans that republicans would
rather have a sexual assaulter on the
court because they'll make the decisions
they want to make than someone who is
[ __ ] qualified to make decisions for
this country
and based on the constitution liberal
conservative or otherwise
you can't even [ __ ] pick a qualified
person
amy coney barrett hides behind her
religious dogma hides her bigotry for
women
specifically for women
behind a religious dogma yeah not
qualified not qualified the reason why
you can't question katangi brown
jackson's religion is because she
doesn't hide behind it
you stupid [ __ ]
mj thank you for the ten dollars
mj in the super chat she says episode
110
we are at 110. this is episode 110 keep
up the great work tony and gabe thank
you very much
i guy
i guy kbj has been successful in spite
of being
an american black woman not because
she is a black woman that's right
thank you for the super chat i guy
gives i guy
some fire
in the chat all right let's go back to
the
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
we got a lot to get to and we're
at the bottom of the second hour we only
have 30 minutes left holy moly now we
went to elon musk
let's see what else oh secret service
the people who are uh threatening joe
are excuse me the people who are
threatening hunter biden are mad that
because they're threatening hunter biden
the secret service
has to pay to protect him
what the [ __ ] did you think was going to
happen
what did you think was going to happen
you're threatening and continuing this
nonsense about hunter biden in his
laptop and you don't think the secret
service are going to protect his life
you people are [ __ ] dumb
you people are dumb
that's how it's going to work is the
secret service is going to protect
the people that you are threatening that
are the that that could compromise the
president
that's right
just like the trump children were
protected
biden's children are protected that's
how it works especially when domestic
terrorists are threatening them
you you tell you [ __ ] tell me you go
over you just type in hunter biden's
laptop or i'm buying on twitter and you
see what the [ __ ] comes up these people
are crazy they're obsessed with that
[ __ ] the same way we had to pay
for protection of anthony fauci
i don't i don't think we should have to
pay for protection of anthony fauci but
we have to we have to because you crazy
[ __ ] psychos are threatening him
the people who are threatening and
inciting violence towards a person are
mad that now we have to provide
protection for them because they're a
government official or they're the
children of a government official and
you're threatening them
by the way
hunter biden isn't even isn't even a
government official
neither is this laptop just just so you
guys know um the twitter
symbol is is trending in stocks
because of course again elon musk bought
i think it was 3 billion is what he put
in 3 billion i here's what i say i think
joe biden should sign an executive order
today
making it so that
as long as elon musk spends any kind of
money on twitter he has to pay double in
taxes so if he spends three billion on
twitter stock
then what he has to do is he have to
spend six billion in taxes that's what i
think taxis [ __ ] into oblivion
already i mean i'm not saying that that
elon musk buying twitter is a bad thing
i don't know we'll see
i think it actually ruins twitter if you
want to know the truth
because now he's going to walk around
like this the [ __ ] the nazi rally guy
with the vest with the patches on it
he's gonna wear that patch he's gonna
wear the twitter patch acting like he
owns him he can tell twitter what to do
that's what he's gonna do he'll tweet it
out don't doubt me
i'll show you the tweet in a couple
weeks when he tweets out how he [ __ ]
thinks he owns twitter
and he can tell us all what to do you
know because he's for freedom of speech
and [ __ ]
he's for freedom you know freedom to use
his his
cryptocurrency that's probably what
it'll be
doubt me
doubt me
uh let's see true social is training
because it sucks no i don't know let's
see
uh
exclusive two
two key tech executives quick trump's
true social after trouble app launch
raising question about the company's
progress as many others languish on the
waiting list
unable to use the platform what course
what did you think wow
this is another duh
duh dummy
like no one thought that true social was
gonna be anything other than a [ __ ]
scam
it's a scam
it's a trump scam like trump university
trump stakes trump water the trump
casinos
trump organization trump foundation
all of them they're all [ __ ] scams
jesus they say that mar-a-lago is a
[ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh it's a [ __ ]
scam
now christina says um
e-t-t-d which is everything trump
touches dies i say this i say everything
trump touches turns to liquid [ __ ]
absolutely everything he touches
turns to liquid [ __ ]
it's not as catchy of a hashtag but you
know
it's a lot catchier in a phrase
now let's see what amy has to say two
execs leaving true social the rats are
already chopping ship
keep up the good work devin nunes that's
the craziest part here is that everyone
everyone
everyone's not you know like to the
sense of
devin nunes left his congressional seat
to be the fall guy
like he's gonna be the fall guy
of truth social here
whatever this ends up especially if it
ends up in a [ __ ] federal criminal
court devin nunes is going to be the
fall guy
like that's the trump mo
is to have someone else pay for his
crimes
i.e michael cohen uh roger stone which
he pardoned paul manafort which he
pardoned
uh probably rudy giuliani we'll see in
the future
and his cfo alan weisselberg
you don't think you don't think
at stuart rhodes the the founder of the
oath keepers enrique tario
the leader of the proud boys you don't
think they're gonna pay for trump's
crimes look at all the people that have
been sentenced to a to prison
that broke into the capital in his name
trying to over turn the government make
him king and dictator
they're already serving prisons prison
sentences their bare feet are on a cold
prison floor right now
paying for the tr crimes that trump
committed
i mean eventually i think he's going to
pay for his crimes don't get me wrong
everyone's like oh he will never pay for
his credit no he's going to he's going
to pay
there's plenty of federal jurisdiction
in state jurisdictions that are oh baby
they're drooling to come after him i
know it doesn't feel like it no alan
bragg or alvin whatever the [ __ ] his
name is bragg the manhattan d.a
well the governor of the state of new
york has got control over that situation
i'm sure
we'll figure that out we'll see that
story to come
[Laughter]
my just touch uh uh post this he'll
report a reporter uh article it says the
truth
is it's a disaster that's the truth
about true social
and it's not really even i mean yeah
disaster
but it was a scam from the get-go this
was never supposed to be a thing other
than a way for him to put money in his
pockets nothing ever is with this
[ __ ]
it's all a scam all of it okay let's go
back to tweet tweets tucker carlson is
trending
duck or carlson
[ __ ] tucker tucker sucks um some
highlights from fox news host tucker
carlson previous comments about russia
and it's president vladimir putin as
evidence emerged over the weekend of
violence
in buca ukraine and its surrounding
areas
i just a and you know here's the thing
there is uh freedom of speech
you do have the right to
say what you want to say
you do not have on the other hand the
right to say what you want to say if
there's collateral damage right like you
can't lead people
um
in a theater that is on fire that's not
on fire and fire you can't you can't do
that you can't go yell fire in a crowded
theater
you can't
can't do that when you are when you are
doing what taco carlson is doing on the
daily over at fox news you are yelling
fire in a crowded theater
these people are [ __ ] lying to you
they're [ __ ] deceiving you
and they're [ __ ] killing people
they're killing people now fox news has
the right to exist
and frankly so does tucker carlson but
they do not have the right
to yell fire in a crowded theater
and i'm not saying you know i i don't
think i don't think getting rid of fox
news is the answer right like this is
this is the whole the whole nonsense
about spotify and getting rid of joe
rogan
you know this idea that if you get rid
of joe rogan and you silence him somehow
someone else won't say this [ __ ]
they're gonna say this [ __ ] and the
people that we just seen at the trump
rally while ago in those clips they're
gonna seek out this information whether
you like it or not
they'll find it they'll find it it's the
it's the it's 2022.
i mean this is not like it's 1970 1980
when it you know you had to actually
work to find
information
and to go to the library
you had to seek out information you just
didn't you know pick up the little
computer in your pocket
the shiny little screen in your pocket
and type in what you want to see
and boom there it is exactly how you
want to see it
that's the reality we live in and until
we come to grips with that
we're up a [ __ ] creep without a paddle
here
if we don't come to grips with that
because i think it's garbage in garbage
out right
like uh
the algorithm everyone wants to blame
facebook or whatever you know we poke
fun at facebook all you guys over there
on facebook
we poke good fun at facebook here but
the algorithm is garbage in garbage out
here's what i mean by that
the algorithm is only going to feed you
what you want it's how it's designed
it's designed to give you
what you want to see what you want to
hear
that's how it's designed
otherwise you wouldn't stay on the
platform i mean can you imagine if you
went on a a social media platform
and it only it fed you
[ __ ] that was you were diametrically
opposed to
how long would you stay on that platform
think about it if you went over to
instagram and all it fed you was
pro-trump lies
trump cult lies just that's uh that's it
that's just over and over and over again
how long would you stay on instagram
you wouldn't stay very [ __ ] long
you wouldn't
that's the design of the algorithm
now
some of us humans
know
that the bots know it for sure
some of us humans know it some humans do
not have any understanding
of how social media and how the [ __ ]
that's in front of them works
what i mean by that is
they think that it's put in front of
them because it's the truth
not just what they want to hear
and and then in that form they don't
question it very well
they're not skeptical
here's the good news i believe
the generation coming up the young
generation coming up
they understand the internet they
understand it they have never lived in a
world without it
most of them have never lived in a world
without a [ __ ] smartphone
almost all of them
have never lived in a world without a
smartphone that they can remember
that's the good news i know it sounds
like bad news but it's good news
it's good news because they know how
what what it is they understand the
animal
better than we could ever imagine
i know it doesn't feel like it like oh
my god these kids are being brainwashed
not necessarily
they really do understand that you
should be skeptical what you see
because they know that most of [ __ ] on
the internet isn't [ __ ] real
most the [ __ ] they look at isn't [ __ ]
real
they know that they know it's all
[ __ ] they know it's designed for
your entertainment they understand that
that's the best part now
that's good news that's a long ways away
right
that's not gonna happen tomorrow
these people are not gonna that these
people that completely understand social
media and the internet are not gonna be
in charge of [ __ ] for a long time
but we have to start to understand that
that
social media algorithms are garbage in
garbage out right
garbage in garbage out
meaning whatever you want to see
whatever garbage you want to see that's
the [ __ ] that it's going to spit out
and as long as you keep putting that
garbage in an algorithm it's going to
keep spitting the garbage out to you
that's why these two and owners get in
such these deep holes
because they keep feeding that algorithm
the crazy
it keeps
launching it right back at them
that's why sam stein
questioning why the american people
don't know what th that the unemployment
rate is 3.6 percent
i can't imagine maybe it's because i
feed the algorithm maybe because the
stories that i write
feed the algorithm the exact opposite
narrative
who to guess that [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ]
i like you sam
i'm beating up on sam stein today
but sam
you deserve
a little bit of flack here
and really honestly
you're gonna get a lot more because
you clearly don't understand
you clearly do not
even from the continuation of you not
understanding from your previous tweets
but the algorithm is garbage and garbage
out and that is a prime example
americans think
that the unemployment rate is going up
it's going up it's not going down
because garbage in garbage out
and they don't know it i have no clue
you think that woman standing in line
who thinks the space force has some kind
of [ __ ]
information that she's privy to because
she read it on facebook and they're
gonna have military tribunals and all
kinds of weird ass [ __ ] and make donald
trump the king of the castle or
whatever the hell that she thinks holy
[ __ ]
whatever kind of delusional [ __ ] she's
read on facebook
you think she understands garbage and
garbage out
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] garbage inc you think she
understands
garbage in garbage out with the
algorithm hell to the [ __ ] no
back to tucker carlson that is the whole
point
it's because fox news had an audience
that is garbage in garbage out
and that's why tucker carlson says the
[ __ ] he says is because the tail is
wagging the dog
garbage in
garbage out
tucker carlson can't tell the truth on
his show
the tail would wag him
they would stop watching he would lose
his advertiser he would lose his show if
he stopped saying the [ __ ] he said
which is not very beneficial to tucker
carlson's pocketbook
you don't think this is all about money
i mean they're fascist
let's be frank they're greedy [ __ ]
fascist for sure
we've seen the atrocities
in buca ukraine
another topic that's trending
uh
of course
vladimir
zelinski
um has visited bucca here's a
a picture of his face
let's make this a little bigger
ah this is such a sad state of affairs
we're gonna try to get uh aaron parnez
and you guys know aaron is the he's a
lawyer but he's also the host of zoomed
in but he has um special insight into
ukraine as he has
relatives that are there in ukraine
and uh communicated we're gonna try to
have him on i think on wednesday so stay
tuned for that for an update of ukraine
and some of this violence and murder and
war crimes that happened in bucca
as you know the russians have been set
back on their heels in many areas
of the ukraine
but they committed atrocities
over the weekend
and in the last week
in bucca
it is gross and disgusting to see
that
vladimir putin continues to
um
commit war crimes on innocent women and
children people on bikes just shooting
them in the street
people walking down the street just
shooting and killing them
they're not part of an army they're not
part of an aggression they're not part
of an opposition
they're just normal average citizens
walking down the street
and they're murdering them
murdering
them war crimes
and all because vladimir putin wants to
destroy democracy
and tucker carlson
donald trump
and the rest of the [ __ ] let's go
brandon nazis in this country don't
understand that
because it goes back to the algorithm
garbage in garbage out
you run down through this [ __ ] you
run down through the comments of some of
the threads
in this buca thread and you'll find
let's go brandon nazis
talking all kinds of crazy [ __ ] about
bio labs talking all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
the ukraines are the aggressors
talking all kinds of [ __ ] that it's all
propaganda that's all faked
they're [ __ ] out of their minds folks
to say the cheese has slid off their
cracker is an insult to the cheese
that's how bad we've gotten
the good news is
is that it's only a small percentage of
people if you've been watching the trump
if you've been watching the trump
rallies you would know there's a lot of
[ __ ] empty seats they don't want you
to know that they don't want you to know
that
because there's a lot of empty seats at
those trump rallies
this idea that somehow he has big
support in this country that's all
[ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] that's what they
want you to believe
they want you to believe that there's
big support for this [ __ ]
and the reason why they want you to
believe that
is because what is happening in ukraine
that's right
just like russia once
russia has to have big support for
vladimir putin with lies
to keep his support for the [ __ ] war
crimes that he's committing in ukraine
you don't think you don't think
the let's go brandon nazis aren't going
to commit war crimes you don't think
they were committing war crimes against
humanity
why do you think they're protecting
hunter biden because they can't get
their [ __ ] minds off of his laptop
that he owned a [ __ ] laptop
look if hunter biden owned a laptop and
he committed crimes at that laptop and
there's evidence on that laptop and the
fbi has it let them [ __ ] go to a
grand jury and if the grand jury finds
that there needs to be charges to indict
him on fine
there is no [ __ ] american out there
that is against that
especially pro-democracy americans
but this is the [ __ ] they keep spreading
this is the [ __ ] they keep doing
this is it
just like vladimir putin is doing in
ukraine
as he commits war crimes and murders
innocent people
this is from the kiev independent
a president
of zielinski that had booked a town
northwest of kiev which became the site
of russia's bloody massacre with
hundreds of civilians
civilian victims on april 4th
visit today here's some more pictures
and i don't know if you guys have seen
some of the pictures of the victims
but we're probably going to get to it
here
and you goddamn right i'm gonna show it
i don't care if [ __ ] youtube takes
the video down or not
we're gonna show these videos are these
these pictures
if i can find them here
people lay dead dead people laying in
the street don't look away
don't look away
mark my words
those [ __ ] delusional [ __ ]
at the nazi rally in michigan
the trump cult rally this weekend
they they would they'll cheer for the
day
they've even said it
they said it at a charlie kirk event
when can we take up arms against
liberals
when can we start using
our weapons against liberals
you don't think that they'll kill
innocent women and children
you don't think that their weakness like
represented mclean said
breeds aggression that's the truth
it does breed aggression it does
weakness breeds fascism
because in weakness
you must seek a power
even if it's a weak
power don't
look
away
russian soldiers are murdering
innocent people in the
streets committing war crimes in the
name of vladimir putin
don't look away
um mj i think sent me a link here
of a video of lincoln project you guys
know we've had our beef with the lincoln
project
we got beef with the lincoln project
but that doesn't mean that doesn't mean
our aim isn't the same
this is a perfect example of what i'm
talking about
of this
this bull side stuff lincoln project is
not
of the both sides narrative
they're not
i believe they're pro-democracy
even though they may
they may lift some of gabe's ideas
we'll deal with that later
let's listen to this video from lincoln
project
people are dying on the front lines do
you think it's a joke how do i care why
do i care about what's going on in the
conflict between ukraine and russia
we're not an ally of ukraine keep saying
ally out we're not you got this minx
accord and stuff kind of bound around
we're not an ally they're not an ally
why shouldn't i root for russia which i
am
about vladimir putin you know i
analogize him to basically an
authoritarian gas station attendant
why does permanent washington hate him
so much
has put never called me a racist
has he threatened to get me fired for
disagreeing with him
putin ain't woke he is anti-woke
no vladimir putin didn't do any of that
he's going to go in and be a peacekeeper
i said how smart is that
in american terms you would call ukraine
a tyranny we've never been an ally
ukraine
that's the strongest peace force i've
ever seen there were more army tanks
than i've ever seen they're going to
keep peace all right
what the russians did was an attack i
don't care
we could use that on our southern border
this is genius
i'm in the city of
and it's curse of the capital
what happened here
and
everywhere in ukraine what is happening
this is not special operation this
island military options with civilians
they've been shot in the head with a
tight hands behind their back
this is a genocide of the ukrainian
population
and that's exactly what
russian regime putin's regime russian
army is doing
killing the civilians
with the tight hands behind their back
and with the shot in their hands
lincoln project with a great
video don't look away
don't look away
it is crucially important that we keep
our eyes on this ball and again this
week i think wednesday we're going to
have aaron parnez on and hopefully we
can have him for a while
uh to ask questions uh to aaron about
ukraine
if you guys want you know what um
maybe we should um you go to the at tony
michael's pod
to the twitter page the podcast twitter
page um or tag us with your questions if
you want us to ask aaron about ukraine
and i'll try to make sure that i get as
many as we can
to ask aaron those questions and i think
we're going to have him on wednesday i
believe so so between today and tomorrow
make sure that you're
just go to the at tony michaels pod
follow us there but just tag us with
your question for aaron tag aaron parnez
um it's i believe his uh tag is at aaron
parnez i believe i'm pretty sure um let
me put it in the um
um
yes it's at aaron parnez let me put it
in the chat here so you guys have it um
if you guys want to go to twitter
and post those questions there is
aaron's handle
at aaron parnez
um oh minus touch is in there oh yeah
okay so at aaron parton as you guys can
see there if you're on facebook or
youtube twitch if you're on twitter
you're already there uh go follow aaron
and then submit your questions just tag
at tony michael's pod and at aaron
barnes
with your question about ukraine and uh
just just mentioning there that you want
this question answered on wednesday i
think that's i i don't think we picked
the time but i think wednesday is a day
that we're gonna have aaron on
um we'll have him live so we'll try to
ask him some of those questions if you
guys have them uh so go over there and
put your questions in we'll try to get
them answered on ukraine we can't look
away from this folks this is uh
that video encapsulates
the republican party they're pro-putin
they're not just pro-putin
they're pro-authoritarianism
they don't care that putin's gonna
murder people what do they care
it's for the cause of authoritarianism i
mean you know
what's the difference
you know liberal democracy small liberal
democracy is worth is worth smashing up
and worth killing a few innocent people
for what's the difference
what's the difference
why not
why tucker carlson
is such a [ __ ] [ __ ] box
that's why
in some degree whether it be with the
pandemic with the coronavirus or in this
case
vladimir putin in russia
tucker carlson is yelling
and screaming
fire in a crowded theater
i wanted to get to randy rainbow's um
speaking of
what in the world happened there
i want to get to randy rainbow's uh
uh video here i think we have it let's
see
yeah there it is okay
here is randy rainbow's um
newest video
it looks like it's called uh gay so say
gay uh speaking of
fascists that want to
ostracize people ron desantis signed the
don't say gay bill in florida and here
is randy rainbow's
video to tell us about it we are back
and i'm joined now by ron desantis
governor of the great state of
wait which is the one that shaped like a
big
florida right florida sir you recently
signed into law the controversial
parental rights and education bill which
some have called the don't say gay bill
and others have called the girl [ __ ]
that bill i think it's probably the most
comprehensive piece of legislation i've
seen critics say that this bigoted
legislation will rob kids of a safe
space to have a healthy discussion about
their identities i mean how would you
feel if we signed a bill prohibiting
everyone from talking about slimy
self-interested douchebag politicians
with no sex appeal who buy all their
suits off the clearance rack at
burlington coat factory we at the state
can stop that i look and see how this
media operates as corporate media what
about all the people they've smeared
over the years who are not governors
someone's being an [ __ ]
that's no way to be
honey d
here's the t
gosh i'd hate to upset your republican
peers so let me say the soft so no one
hears
i've
always
been
here's an interesting fact
oops i said it i'm gay
you can bet it's a badge that i wear
with a fabulous flower cause i'm kkk
sorry honey i'm here
that's a drag queen's brush
and although you might think that i'm
flawed hey i'm gay as a broadway
premiere
all your thinly veiled late
is the dangerous trend it's such a fun
cliche but you'd rather talk
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm as gay as the cast
[Music]
[Applause]
i almost said it again god i'm sorry i
don't know what came over me
[Music]
i'm not backing down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for ending the show on a great note um
everyone go spread this video around
what a fantastic fantastic
fantastic
piece of art from randy rainbow again
never disappoints
always always
gives us
just what we need you know i think
that's one lesson maybe these fascists
can learn down in florida
is that one community you don't [ __ ]
with is the arts community a big huge
ally of lgbtq
plus community
the arts
you don't [ __ ] with the arts
they will bury you in fantastic content
as randy rainbow does we all love randy
here and say gay go out there and say
gay
over and over and over again especially
in front of the people who it offends it
is high time in this country that we
start [ __ ] offending people
the correct people that is the correct
people until tomorrow noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
and twitch don't forget we are also
we're also on the minus touch facebook
page every single weekday go download
every single episode
on spotify apple your favorite directory
give us a five star review there while
you're downloading
until tomorrow at noon eastern 11
central
nine pacific
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking